there is so much to commemorate today
it's Halloween it's Reformation day it's
trigger a college student in 2017 day so
festive we will discuss why lefties are
so angry about Moana and then top 10
myths about Martin Luther then Donald
Trump jr. trolls Hillary British
socialized medicine bans fat people from
getting surgery and the Podesta group
might drop the name Podesta because then
they won't be criminals who colluded
with Russia or something I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I got to tell you I am so embarrassed I
should make a pre-emptive apology but by
the time I had bought my eight-year-old
Moana costume at Party City it was only
after that that I read the Cosmo article
that Moana is racist it's racist to wear
the Disney Princess costume so I'm
really I'm really sorry it's just a I
guess a pre-emptive apology obviously
was too late to get a new costume so I'm
here I already I already had to slit
open the back so really my sincere
apologies maiya culpa mea culpa
according to Cosmo according to Cosmo
and bulletin boards at elementary
schools and colleges across the country
but I repeat myself it is racist for
white people to wear Moana costumes now
luckily I am a bit swarthy so I might
get away with it that is possibly the
saving grace is my sicilian background
but faith more the daughter of the lord
of the multiverse Andrew Clavin has a
good piece of pj explaining how the the
left completely misunderstands what
Disney Princesses are so they they say
if you are not Arabic then you can't be
jasmine or something if you're not
Middle Eastern you can't be Jasmine if
you're not Hawaiian or Polynesian then
you can't dress up as Moana and the
premise there is that the essential
aspect of these Disney Princesses is the
color of their skin when obviously that
is not the case the essence of
Cinderella the heart of the Cinderella
story is not that she's a white girl the
heart of Rapunzel is not that she's a
white girl the wait what excuse me I
know this is pretty shocking even Beauty
and the Beast even Beauty and the Beast
the heart of it is not that Belle is a
white girl honestly even snow white
which is one that were it's right in the
name is white you know it's a German
fairy tale but even that isn't about the
race right it's about that she's the the
fairest one of them all it is it's a
fairy tale and it's a metaphor you know
it's obviously a metaphor about her
spiritual fairness and her inner beauty
and her inner fairness compared to that
wicked old stepmother so it I think the
left as usual misses the point but
they're pouncing on censoring Halloween
costumes for a reason
let's not forget that that craziness at
Yale with the
student Geralyn Luther's screaming at
her professor saying this is not an
intellectual space that's by creating a
home that was over a halloween costume
that was over an email that that
professors wife had sent out saying that
ostensibly 18 to 22 year olds at one of
the elite universities in the world can
dress themselves they don't need
teachers to hold their hands and lay out
their costumes for them and the reason
the left pounces on this is because if
you scratch a leftie deep enough you'll
get a totalitarian they love censorship
because at this moment the left leftist
view of the world is is an unwrap on its
it's an uneven it's it's it borders into
relativism and it's one in which
different competing groups with
competing interests have to yell at each
other and who are whoever's loudest wins
it's not one where we can have follow
logic through a dialogue to arrive at a
logical conclusion this is where Shapiro
gets the phrase facts don't care about
your feelings right it isn't just people
who have no recourse to reason and no
recourse to logic screaming and bashing
each over the head now they try to ban
the speakers at college campuses they
try to ban ban or Charles Murray or
christina hoff sommers
and they catch a little flak for that
because they're shutting down a
reasonable lecture but they because
Halloween costumes are not inherently
logical they're not really about ideas
per se they try to ban them to flex
their censorship muscles and that
impulse becomes unrestrained so I you
know I Pro should have thought this
through because we had the rest of the
show is it deals with serious matters
you know like the Protestant revolution
important Luther and everything that's
in the news but I can't change out of my
Moana costume so enough about Moana it
is Halloween but it's also Reformation
day in full Moana attire I will turn the
potpourri up to 11 and delve into the
top 10 myths about Martin Luther number
one Martin Luther did not set off a
Reformation he set off a revolution this
is just a matter of definition rather
than reforming his own ecclesiastical
institution he didn't do that he didn't
change the Catholic Church and Martin
Luther's action
led to the break away of countless
churches throughout Europe and the world
GK Chesterton described him as one of
those great elemental barbarians to whom
it is indeed given to change the world
and the excellent historian jock bars
and credits the Protestant revolution
with initiating a modernity which he
describes brilliantly in his book from
dawn to decadence highly recommended
number two Martin Luther most likely
never posted his 95 theses to the door
of the All Saints Church in Wittenberg
you know that famous line I got 99
problems but the Pope ain't one bang
bang bang probably didn't happen he
certainly sent them to Albert of
Brandenburg the Archbishop of maine's
but there's no evidence that he ever
nailed the theses to the door he never
wrote about it he never wrote about
posting the theses and claims to the
effect that he did didn't appear until
thirty years after the alleged event
number three this is the big one this
one's gonna take a little while because
people really misunderstand this one
Luther did not cause the church the
Catholic Church to end a long-standing
practice of selling eternal life through
indulgences yeah that's just a lie it is
stunning how little people understand
about a concept that is so central to
the Protestant revolution and to the
modern era as indulgences let's
establish a definition an indulgence is
quote a remission before God of the
temporal punishment due to sins whose
guilt has already been forgiven which
the faithful Christian who is duly
disposed gains under certain defined
conditions through the church's help
when as a minister of redemption
she dispenses and applies with authority
the Treasury of the satisfaction one by
Christ and the Saints if that was too
many words for you your sins have
already been forgiven and the
indulgences that one gets rare times in
history by donating to charities or
giving arms that indulgence is for the
temporal relief it's for the relief of
penance it's not for popping out of
purgatory a thousand years early and
it's not for going from Hell to heaven
now it's true that there were some
corrupt professional partners who
extorted money in exchange for bogus
promises there were forgers who sold
fake indulgences but none of this had
any agreement with Church doctrine
in fact as early as 1215 centuries
before Martin Luther the fourth Lateran
council suppressed abuses of indulgences
by strictly re articulating the limits
of their scope in 1392 more than a
century before the 95 theses pope
boniface the ninth wrote to the Bishop
of Ferrara to condemn members of
religious orders who were fraudulently
claiming that the Pope had authorized
them to sell the forgiveness of sins to
ignorant and hopeful faithful now
because indulgences strictly refer to
temporal penance the Rouen Cathedral has
been nicknamed the butter tower this
this Cathedral in France the butter
tower because some of its funding came
from the sale of indulgences that
allowed the faithful to eat butter
during the penitential period of Lent
when theoretically they should have been
abstaining you know they shouldn't have
very flavorful food it's a time to kind
of do some penance and think about the
the sinful nature of a man out of this
world even this sale is misleading
because no one could ever buy
indulgences outright rather they had to
give alms to some charity of course it's
easy to see how abuses would creep in in
that case but you couldn't you it wasn't
like you write a check and you get a
receipt and that's it there is at least
there was always at least the veneer of
donating to some charity now even if
there's a difference between selling a
40-day butter eating pass and purporting
to sell eternal life pope pius v at the
council of trent forbade all grants of
indulgences involving any fees or other
financial transactions to severely
address any abuses this was a couple
decades three or four decades after
Martin Luther very shortly thereafter
Martin Luther this is number four Martin
Luther was not terribly pluralistic he
led to this breakaway of the church and
all these various sects and
denominations he himself was not
terribly pluralistic as some might think
it is true he did say quote let the Turk
believe and live as he will just as one
lets the papacy and other false
Christians live that's fairly tolerant
he also said as the Pope is Antichrist
so the Turk is the very devil of the
Jews and I'm quoting one sentence
out of a long a long literature
describing Martin Luther's thoughts on
the Jews he said quote eject them
forever from this country first to set
fire to their synagogues or schools and
to bury and cover with dirt whatever
will not burn so that no man will ever
again see a stone or a cinder of them
not very tolerant number five Martin
Luther did not unchain the Bible so that
the common man could read it there is a
myth that before the Protestant
revolution Bibles were put under lock
and chain literally they were locked up
so the common man could not read them
now they were frequently attached to a
chain as were all large books at the
time so that people couldn't steal them
because books were very expensive but
Bibles were available everywhere in
whole book form prayer books stained
glass windows and artwork scripture was
everywhere number six this leads
directly into number six Martin Luther
was not the first to translate the Bible
into a common language this is obviously
true because st. jerome translated the
Bible into Latin then the common
language in the fourth century when
Luther began his work when he began his
Bible translation there were already
eighteen German translations of the
entire Bible going around number seven
Martin Luther was not a populist we have
this idea this common perception of him
as a man of the people
retrieving Christianity back from
oppressive elites but Luther had fairly
harsh words for German peasants one need
only consult his book this is the title
against the murderous thieving hordes of
peasants and and his subsequent defense
of that book open letter on the harsh
book against the peasants and we can
understand that Luther's we can
understand Luther's guilt and confusion
at having inspired the peasant war by
his theological proclamations this
brings us to number eight a difference I
suppose between Luther and the
Lutheran's between Luther and people who
followed in his tradition Martin Luther
believed at the literal presence of
Christ in the Eucharist he wrote quote
who but the devil has granted such a
license of resting the words of the Holy
Scripture who ever read in the
scriptures that my body is the same as
the sign of my body or that it is the
as it signifies what language in the
world ever spoke so it is only then the
devil that imposes upon us by these
fanatical men not one of the Fathers of
the Church
though so numerous ever spoke of the
sacrament Ariens not one of them ever
said it is only bread and wine or the
body and blood of Christ is not their
present he fully believed that the the
Eucharist is the body of Christ not that
there is some it's a symbol of the body
of Christ or it's some remnant that we
have of the body of Christ number nine
Martin Luther added a word to the Bible
this is also little known but while
prior and virtually all subsequently
revised versions of the Bible translate
Romans 3:28 to read quote for we hold
that one is justified by faith apart
from the works of the law Luther
translated that passage as quote so now
we hold that man is justified without
the help of the works of the law alone
through faith that addition of a loan is
is theologically important the
implications of this creativity would
become very important as the Protestant
revolution progressed into our modern
era but quite creative a little addition
there and number 10 more than Luther
obviously didn't like the Pope very much
he did not like that Authority but he
did defer to at least one theological
authority outside of the Bible on at
least one occasion and that man's name
was Martin Luther Luther addressed
Catholic criticisms of his translation
in his open letter on translating he
said quote please do not give these
donkeys any other answer to their
useless braying about that word Sola
only then simply this Luther will have
it so and he says that he is a doctor
above all the doctors of the Pope let it
rest there I will from now on hold them
in contempt and have already held them
in contempt as long as they are the kind
of people or rather donkeys that they
are and there are brazen idiots among
them who have never even learned their
own art of sophistry like dr. Schmitt or
dr. snot-nosed and such like them who
set themselves against me in this matter
which not only transcends
Astri but as Paul writes all the wisdom
and understanding in the world as well
truly a donkey does not have to sing
much because he is already known by his
ears that is all obviously an
interpretation of judge not lest ye be
judged
okay I have braids enough on the topic
of Reformation day let's bring on our
panel to discuss the news we have an
excellent expert panel today we have
Ally Stuckey we have Dale wires own
Jacob Airy and for the first time on the
panel of deplorable z-- my pal Kyra
Davis now I I know look I know that you
want to listen to them I know you want
to see them especially kiri you've never
heard from Kyra on this show I got to
tell you something guys this is
Halloween in order to keep me in moaña
costumes these things are very expensive
by the way even though you have ripped
them up to make them fit onto a grown
man you got to go to daily wire comm we
have a second by to Facebook and YouTube
right now if you go to daily wire calm
right now and you're already a
subscriber you watch the rest of the
show thanks for subscribing keeping the
lights on in this place keeping me in
these kind of cheap costumes and employ
at least for another day if you're not
then go over there it's $10 a month $100
a year you get me you get the indra
Clavin show you get the Ben Shapiro show
blah blah blah blah blah but you get
this you get I got to tell you guys I
they were sold out of mulana costumes
one of the stories I went to there are
going to be the leftist tears flowing
from the heavens it is going to be
Noah's Ark part two speaking of
Reformation day and new new advances
into Christianity so make sure that you
go to daily wire.com get this leftist
tears tumblr the finest vessel for salty
hot or cold leftist ears in the world
subscribe on youtube subscribe on
facebook we'll be right back
all right panel I feel like we have just
beaten Moana and poor Martin Luther to
death here so I want to get into the
really important news that obviously is
changing our country Donald Trump Jr's
tweet and Hillary Clinton's stupid
comments asked on Monday what she would
dress as for Halloween Hillary Clinton
responded I think I will maybe come as
the president so Donald Trump jr.
responded and he said that's cute she
can borrow my Donald Trump mask
Jakub which is scarier rather which is
the scariest is the Hillary Clinton as
president costume the most frightening
costume that has ever been posted for
Halloween oh yeah most definitely
I saw someone posted a a comic strip I
believe it was busy I believe it was
Michael Ramirez I could be wrong but it
was a girl dressed as Hillary and she
wouldn't leave the house that she got
the candy from and the parent and the
people passing out the candy were like
oh that's a nice touch yeah it's
especially scary it's like Hillary
Clinton won't go away and now we have to
endure all these masks of her and all
these blue costume there are all these
blue dresses that she used to wore her
pants a famous pant suits which by the
way were all around long before Hillary
Clinton ever wore them Oh fair enough I
also this is apropos of nothing I
recently learned Winston Churchill
invented the male romper the romp that's
just a little tie in with a with the
Hillary Clinton suits Kyra if Hillary
Clinton went as Donald Trump for
Halloween would that be culturally
appropriate --iv of cantaloupe colored
Americans it's really important that we
stick to our own race when we're doing
costumes you should never want to be
like someone else you should never want
to elevate someone of another race or
gender as as someone you aspire to be
and you got to keep them in their place
you got to keep those people
in their place so your options for
Halloween costumes are very limited and
I think Hillary and Donald I mean
they're very compatible looks way so
they both ran for president they're both
rich you know we all like to pretend we
all like to dream and fantasizing and
she's still fantasizing about being the
president thanks Vera in her Lane and
you know Trump was a Democrat for many
years so she's staying in her Lane
brutal brutal but possibly true ally
ally people keep describing Donald Trump
as unpresidential meanwhile a losing
presidential candidate is parading
around the country stoking conspiracy
theories blaming everyone else on earth
for her loss and questioning the results
of an American election who is really
being unpresidential here well jr.
absolutely wins the troll of the year I
mean this truly is like right up there
with Michael Dean old dog to me
it's really really good y'all get
together and like teach at rollin 101
class into these cringe-worthy
situations I mean for crying out loud
she which I am NOT the person who made
this joke I've seen this several times
but she wrote the first book with the
question and answer on the cover
what happened Hillary Clinton she keeps
on walking into these situations in
which people can still obviously point
out both her income a incompetency is
that a word I think it is but that's not
what I was going to say and just her her
complete lack of self awareness about
both who she is now and I guess I don't
know who she believes people see her I
think she has a very inflated view of
her own um her own popularity no she
seems pretty humble to me she seemed no
you know as speaking of Hillary's
cultural appropriation and her inflated
view of herself and lack of common touch
this was up until about three weeks ago
you can still find it on the Wayback
Machine on Hillary Clinton calm on her
campaign website there was an article
titled seven ways Hill
Clinton is just like your abuela and it
used these various Spanish words like it
said Hillary Clinton in your abuela both
understand the importance of el respeto
you know and they keep like going with
these little al font on the respect or
whatever the heck you know and this was
up for almost a year after her election
laws the the the cultural appropriation
eventually got us before the 2017
Halloween season but truly truly out of
touch a local Health Committee in the
United Kingdom's socialized medicine
regime has just announced that for an
indefinite amount of time it will ban
access to routine or non urgent surgery
for the obese and for smokers Jacob
isn't universal health care just great
oh yeah I mean it's wonderful but my
question is how are they going to how
are they are they gonna make this happen
because there are some people who have
like legitimate health reasons and
that's why they're over weights are they
just not going to are they just not
going to give surgeries to to you just
period if you go over a certain weight
that doesn't make any sense to me I
think it's I think it's in the smoking
to Jacob I mean sometimes I get a little
tired after a day of work that's my
physically I get a little tired so I
need to have a little nicotine a nice
Cuban cigar to relax
exactly medicine science exactly and
like what next thing is the British
universal health care system is going to
say hey you have a risk that's a
pre-existing condition we're not going
to give you a hand that you're hand
surgery because you have a wrist I mean
this this is the logic as far out as it
can play out and I think it's just
despicable especially when you have
people like Bernie Sanders saying we
need a universal health care system like
Canada and England I mean it's just the
most ridiculous thing and that's why a
good old-fashioned American private
health care system is what we need I did
not expect that Jewish New York accent
from that man Jake a very well done sir
you bring up this great point of the
pre-existing condition we're now seeing
in a socialized medicine regime the
reintroduction of pre-existing condition
clauses like obesity to keep the costs
down because the cost starts soaring
Kyra in a socialized health care regime
is it necessary to ration care
like this if taxpayers are funding
someone else's surgery don't they
deserve a say and how that person can
live their lives well I have an
interesting perspective on this because
I'm actually Canadian and I was born and
raised in Canada I moved to the US as
soon as I finished high school because I
liked America better learning Canadians
but I did grow up under socialized
health care and I was a victim of
rationing and I know many people who
have been and are it is a real thing
that happens what happens is when you
give the government control over your
health care you give them control over
every decision so everything you do can
be under the government purview it's
really like a free ticket to fascism I
mean if they decide yes that I eat that
sugar is bad for you then they can start
saying look we either have to ban sugar
or we have to ban people from eating
sugar or ban people from getting
surgeries if they've eaten sugar because
this is then this is their desiccate
justification for everything everything
is well we're all paying for this and
it's not fair and so you're right
Michael you hit the nail on the head
like what ends up happening it's a
pre-existing condition ends up coming
back because the government says oh well
now that we're paying for it you know we
can't afford for you to take liberties
with the things you eat and drink and
even things like the places you go and
how much outdoor time you get how much
time you spend on the couch like all of
those things begin to come into play
when you give the government that much
power over your life so I can tell you
as someone who has been turned away from
a hospital with pneumonia hey we have no
beds you can probably get better at home
you know that this is the end game of
socialized medicine it's inevitable and
I'll tell you my mom so lives in Canada
she's a senior citizen now and she is
very low on that list of priorities the
government does
a equation the babies to pass out funds
and treatment and she's on the low end
of that equation so there are times when
they say look we've measured out how
much you we think you have of your life
left versus like what a younger person
has we don't know if this treatment is
the best for you you know we'll go with
the cheaper like a plank Obama so will
give you the pill and she comes here to
the US and you know I'll be like I don't
feel good I'm gonna call the doctor and
I get in that day and she's just like
blown away that I can get into the
doctor and you know and my thing is but
this is what you get when you pay for it
that's right and they've got that
equation they know what her health is
worth they know what her life is worth
they don't worry those technical that's
they figured it all out there's the
algorithm and oops sorry we can't give
you any medicine whatsoever a government
big enough to give you anything you want
is big enough to take everything you
have a wise man once said Ali are we
inevitably heading down this path
towards socialized medicine do people
people now expect health care as a right
in the United States are we headed there
whether we want it or not I don't really
have very rosy view of what we can do
with health care because our Republicans
have thus far failed us but if they can
get their act together then there is
certainly hope for it actually being
revealed to replace it maybe were on the
way to that but then then the New York
Times might say mean things about John
McCain so I don't I don't think we're
gonna be able to grab that vote they
might they might be mean to him so they
really matter their opinions are really
credible right yeah you're giving
everyone here's a formality but the
quality of care actually goes down to
it's not compassionate at all we hear
the rhetoric all the time but Michael I
really want to talk to you about the
Reformation all right we have a little
extra time bring it on I did so I was
thinking about bringing His Eminence
Paul Bois on the panel today but I
figured since the first entire half of
the show was all potpourri potpourri up
to 11 I'd make it a fully Protestant
panel for the for the second half yes
lay it on me
absolutely correct it is true that if
you probably never nailed the 95 95
species up on the door in fact he had no
intention whatsoever of revolutionising
the church or even reforming the church
the letter that he actually wrote to the
archbishop that you mentioned was almost
human sounded like sick of man he I mean
he was sucking up to him so much he was
this very kind of in the beginning this
very humble guy who just said hey just
FYI there are priests and there are
people at professional coronation
indulgences and they think these
indulgences count for salvation we
probably should fix that so it wasn't so
much that he was accusing the church
leaders necessarily of directly saying
that hey these indulgences are tied to
your salvation but that there were
allowing people to believe that he felt
like they either intentionally or
unintentionally they were leveraging the
guilt of the people to believe that
these indulgences in some way paid for
their sin and that was the problem that
he presented which is why he presented
the ninety-five theses of course we also
know that Martin Luther wasn't this
perfect guy you read some of his folks
that were also an accurate description
of him but of course we can't use his
character to necessarily invalidate his
entire theology I think the best thing
that Martin Luther and probably the
biggest thing I disagreed with you on
but the best thing that Martin Luther
presented were the five SOLAS of course
the biggest one being by faith alone and
that was his greatest contention with
the Catholic Church and also his
greatest accomplishment and breaking
away from the Catholic Church because in
his belief they had been contaminated so
much in the 16th century into believing
just as the Pharisees did that somehow
their salvation was also was also earned
by works or also were earned through
sacraments and he said that's actually
antithetical to what the guy
so preaches if that was the case if it
was fake and something else if it was by
grace through faith and money by grace
through faith and works and Jesus would
not have had to die he wouldn't have had
to die sure he would expect he would
have just come and said hey Peter on
this rock I build my church okay great
I'm heading up now he would not have had
to die of rusyn death and be resurrected
and so what Martin Luther said even
though yes he was not the first one to
translate scripture for all the common
people he reminded people you do not
need a priest you do not need sacraments
to go to the throne of God confidently
that is exactly why Jesus died because
Jesus is your intercessor no one else no
man in a robe no one else and I'm not
even seeing the Catholics especially
Catholics today believe that but that's
what Martin Luther was standing up for
and now of course he's dragged through
the mud for dividing the church and
causing this chasm which he absolutely
did but it was for the sake of salvation
because intentionally or unintentionally
people who are being led to believe that
indulgences in pain for their sins in
some monetary way or through works was
how they were going to gain salvation
and that completely maligned the cross
of Christ and Martin Luther raised
awareness about that and for that I am
extremely think there is I will I will
grant he did change over time but he did
change over time so earlier on he was a
little bit better more of a reformer
than late later on all of the
anti-semitic comments came later in his
life they weren't they didn't come
earlier in his life however let's not
forget that he did add that first Sola
that only faith from Romans he added
that and and in subsequent translations
[Music]
if it was and of course Ali be a little
bit holier act a little bit better if
that was the case you would have been
totally fine with Pharisees because the
Pharisees were the holiest of them all
but obviously it wasn't about works it
was about faith of course but I think
it's a straw man I don't see anywhere in
church teaching where the Catholic
Church has ever taught
through works you will earn your
salvation the church explicitly didn't
call that a heresy
that's the heresy of Pelagius in the
fourth or fifth century v and we do know
i'm certain of course Christ's sacrifice
was perfect but let's not forget that
that Christ says to Peter Peter you are
this your Arak on this rock I'll build
my church here are the keys to the
kingdom of heaven whatever you loose on
earth will be loosed in heaven whatever
you bind on earth will be bound in
heaven he also said there will be many
who come to me and say Lord Lord who
will not see the kingdom of heaven and
of course James says faith without works
is dead because what Martin Luther did
if she said this is not about your
external proof of whether you are saved
or not this is about your heart and I'm
not saying the entirety of the Catholic
faith faith preaches otherwise but he
felt where he was that that was the
trend that was going on at least the
people in the Catholic Church we're
starting to focus too much on the outer
works and not enough on truth repentance
in their heart and that's exactly what
Martin Luther came to refocus the church
on was focusing on the heart
transformation that grace through faith
actually accomplishes because you're
right faith without works is dead but
works without faith is nothing sure what
the when is the catholic church ever
taught otherwise when does the catholic
church ever taught that you'll earn your
way to heaven through works I don't I
don't deny that there were corrupt
professional partners obviously as many
Pope's condemned them explicitly but if
Martin Luther's problem was with some
local bishops and some local priests
selling heaven they were trying to sell
heaven to ignorant people then then
that's a political conversation that's
not a theology refuge how he just said
that the the issue is the issue is
instead of saying okay Luther Martin
Luther we'll look this over we'll talk
about this he was persecuted for coming
to his art archbishop and saying these
things he was brought and told to say me
a coke
for him and instead of and instead of
doing that he stood his ground and of
course like as you said years later he
seemed to become a little bit embittered
but let's not forget that's a statement
sure yeah well as my as I'm saying you
know it was because Catholic mobs
attacked his followers and and burned
them at the stake and stoned them well
if anybody was a proponent of burning at
the stake I think we would all agree
that Martin Luther was a was a proponent
sure and I'm not gonna defend Martin
Luther in his entirety after all if
there was one thing Catholics and
Protestants were united and it was the
persecution of the early evangelicals of
course they weren't called that back
then but you know that exactly what alia
said it's more about bye-bye faith alone
and standing up to the corruption of his
day you know I will bring up this point
though because I am sympathetic to a lot
of these poor Protestant arguments and I
do like a lot of Protestant theologians
and apologists but it there is this one
sticking point because the the question
here especially with Luther is is the
church the church is the Pope in the
Petrine line in the line of Peter and
did Christ Institute a real church on
earth with a real clergy and real
buildings and real windows in real
places or is it a strictly an ethereal
sort of thing that floats about and does
not have real clergy and real windows
and things like that and it just seems
to me that you know in a religion which
is based on a fact it's not based on a
philosophy it's based on a fact the
incarnation of the Divine logos into a
particular person in it through a
particular motherboard by someone named
Pontius Pilate and then was a literally
resurrected stayed around for six weeks
and then ascended into heaven that it
makes sense to me that that guy would
have picked 12 real people to be the
apostles and when he said I establish a
church would have established a real
institution on earth it's it's hard for
me to get beyond that and to think that
really there was there's a there's all
fact a unity of the symbol and the
symbolized of the logos
and the creator in the creation but then
it just becomes if you're real after
that I will give we're we're gonna get
to the Podesta group that's way less
interesting than this and it is
Reformation day so I will give my
Protestant panel the last word around
the horn Kyra any thoughts you know in
my teenage years so all of these
arguments about to me reprobate today is
nothing more than a historical
discussion and all has been just because
of how I came to faith all I can say is
I'm listening to you guys talk and I
find it fascinating if someone who loves
and who loves history and and theology
I'm I'm a huge theology nut I read
everything I can get my hands on but I
at the end of the day for me everything
you're talking about none of it is a
Salvation issue and I did not I don't
need to you know condescend or say that
because these issues aren't important
than that they're not important to you
Michael as a pathway or to you Allison
as a Protestant I mean I guess they're
important to us all and it is important
to be able to understand the nature of
God and what he did but I also think at
the end of the day I really truly do
believe I mean I pursue a relationship
with God because before him I was empty
and before him I was lost and before him
I was headed to a life that I don't know
if I'd still be living this day so for
me I'm my only motivation is to ever is
to be closer to Christ and to be and to
learn how to live I believe that this is
the life we have been given we're not
waiting for heaven that battle come but
we should be waiting for heaven and we
should be working on you know our
relationships with each other and our
relationship to God's kingdom here on
earth so for me I mean I'm listening to
these things and I'm like oh yes
interesting angels
yeah I don't I don't care that much I
mean for me it's just something it's all
about the Jesus come on stop it
I'm just trying to work out my treasure
in heaven ally any final thoughts all of
these things I believe at least are not
central to the conversation about the
gospel I believe that if you believe in
by grace through faith alone that Jesus
alone is what grants you salvation and
reconciles you to God that all of this
other stuff is its supplemental at
secondary it doesn't actually matter
towards one of our salvation I do think
it's important and it's also very it's
fascinating I mean you mentioned whether
the church is a real physical Church or
whether it's some ethereal thing I think
that's actually kind of a false
dichotomy I don't before the Catholic
Church in some ethereal random thing
that Protestants believe in that we
don't know how to tie into we believe
that it's the body of Christ and if it's
by grace through faith whether you're
part of the Catholic Church or whether
you're on a plane in Africa but you
believe that Jesus alone is true for
salvation then you are part of the body
of Christ and to say that the church
only exists within the walls of
Catholicism is a very small mind view in
my view of what Christianity what the
body of Christ truly is which is this
living being dynamic thing that is
predicated on one's faith in christ and
not sacraments not being a part of the
Catholic Church nothing like that
because in my view that just adds
something to the gospel it is by grace
through faith and if all of us believe
that whether you are Lutheran whether
you're a Calvinist whether you are
whether you're a Catholic and that's
really the only thing that matters but
the question of course is I'm sorry go
ahead guy no the question is did did
Christ Institute that church did he
Institute those sacraments did he say
you have the power to forgive sins did
he say you break this bread and eat it
memory me misunderstanding among
Protestants what the sacraments are for
it's been explained to me by someone who
is devoutly Catholic and he explained it
very well because at one point I was
under the impression that sacraments
were actually necessary for salvation
he explained that they're not necessary
for salvation to keep pointed to the
points of Scripture in which he believed
they were actually derived from but it
is all about Jesus it's all about that's
what's necessary for salvation to Jesus
all the other stuff maybe it's
instituted by Christ but it all follows
from that at the ad that's absolutely
right all right Jacob but we've just
heard excellent points from Ali and Kyra
how are you going to end this discussion
on a low note I'm sure everybody hears
in the body of Christ but Jacob I mean
come on man I don't know what my whole
thing is I think this is actually really
good for Catholics Protestants and
evangelicals to talk about these things
because I agree with Ali in the end it's
and as you also reiterated Michael and
Kyra it's also about Christ and in Jesus
and I think like for instance the church
I went to seminary and they always
invite Catholic leaders and vicars and
priests to teach and they don't issue a
letter of correction after they preach
they just let them come and they let
them preach and I think that if we saw
more unity like that in the body of
Christ whether again like your Catholic
Protestant evangelical all this stuff
all these wounds happened over 500 years
ago maybe some of them sooner but we
need to come together as one body when
faith and work together so I think these
conversations that we're having we
should we should have them because I
think it represents a good coming
together to talk about our differences
as Peter and Paul did in the Bible
absolutely right
[Music]
that we also forget we have damn that
point at the end well - to quote Martin
Luther it is because Kyra Davis says so
that I believe that excellent discussion
thank you all for being here and
excellent an excellent reform of the
Reformation day topic earlier in the
show we have Ally Stuckey
we have Jacob berry for the first time
on the show Kira Davis thanks for being
here I am Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Noel's show I'm gonna now change
out of my mallanna costume so that I
don't go trick-or-treating and
traumatize the drama dies everyone in
Hollywood who hasn't already been
traumatized gets room how about
questions in for this Thursday and we'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
you